that's right a video game review ps5
exclusive game which
am i wasting my time i feel like for a
lot of people watching this is like yeah
this is what you have to look forward to
because you know how many people out
there all the people who have a ps5 so
this video is for all of you out there
who either have a ps5 are hoping to get
a ps5
or you just like hearing me prattle on
about video games and if that's you
any case let's talk about some really
fun video game
so ratchet and clank rift apart is not
resident evil eight sorry
for people who want me to talk about
resident evil 8 you just want me to talk
about one thing
giant vampire mills in there for about
20 max of the entire game 20 glorious
percents so the ratchet and clank
franchise has been around since the ps2
era it's funny enough it's one of those
games that i just
i haven't played not that i've been
against it it's just is one of those
game franchises that just it passed me
by i was playing other stuff so this is
my introduction to ratchet and clank
relevant to address because i can tell
you that you don't have to have played
the other games to enjoy this one you're
going to get more out of it for sure
you're going to get more of the
references you're going to be oh
the love letter to those characters
which is perfect it's good for long time
ratchet and clank fans
and new ratchet and clank fans i say
that because after you play this you
will be a ratchet and clank fan so if
you know
the next best ratchet and clank game
please comment below let me know
as they say because i want to play
another one after this so i feel like
i've
rambled for long enough so when ratchet
and clank rift apart it has to do with
dr nefarious
finds this other world this alternate
dimension where he has won
in this alternate world this alternate
dimension takes ratchet and clank
to a new adventure a new adventure where
there's dr nefarious and
emperor nefarious and this ratchet and
clank and rivet and kt-7461
every one has an opposite and instead of
dividing the gameplay between ratchet
and clank and rivet and kt 7461
who has another name but it's kind of
you know you got to get there in the
game rivet pairs
up with clank at a point you know they
kind of swap back and forth which is
actually really smart to do when you're
introducing new characters you don't
want to just play as the other
characters like other new characters a
new sidekick and
i feel kind of alone now when you're
playing as rivet you have clank with
rivet for a bit so there's that
familiarity but that was really smart to
do it's a good way to bring new
characters into the fold what i liked
about this game is each world
looks and feels very distinct their
glorious worlds they look fantastic and
on a few of them there's a logistic
involved there that's just very unique
to that world one in particular you have
to hit these crystals to go into the
other dimensions
solve puzzles by hitting the crystal and
going back you know that was
i love that also showcases the load
times that's why it's a ps5 game
instead of hiding the load screen with
this big animations like
lightning and whatnot you know and the
whole time it's doing that it's like
the system's going all right let's load
really quickly while they're entertained
with this cut scene that's why that
happens this one's just like clack
blam different world and that's why this
game is a great showcase for the ps5
also
skipped over i should have talked about
this before i started talking about
gameplay but here we are the game looks
fantastic like miles morales before it
you have the performance which is 60
frames a second smooth as butter or you
have the high fidelity that has all the
ray tracing and it looks
amazing like head exploding amazing i
haven't captured any footage because
the capture that i have it won't show it
plus i upload in 1080 anyway what's the
point you won't be able to see what i
saw so i'll use generic trailer footage
that works regardless two things remain
a fact like miles morales before it they
there's this middle ground where it's
like oh it's 60 frames a second
and you get some of the ray tracing but
not all the ray tracing which i played
on for a bit i was like ooh it's 60
frames a second still looks a mill oh
this is great
great middle ground you can't even tell
the difference until you go back to the
ray tracing one
and you see the difference you're like
but no this just looks better and the
other fact is all your pc gamer friends
are like
aren't your first time gaming in this
quality isn't that precious
whatever there's someone who wasn't
attached to the characters before i
played this game
i love the characters in this game
ratchet ribbit doctor nefarious emperor
nefarious all the voice acting it's
great it's top notch it's like
watching an animation that you and your
kids
can all enjoy like everyone's gonna
enjoy this everyone's gonna get a laugh
everyone's gonna get a chuckle
everyone's gonna be entertained
as for the world's looking and playing
amazing and feeling very distinct
the size was a very it was a satisfying
size because it's not like the worlds
are the biggest things ever it's like
it's big enough for you to do the
mission and come back and clean up a bit
you know completion is you want to get
that platinum trophy but you're not
going to spend a lot of time on the
worlds
after you're done maybe you can come
back and be like oh there's a good farm
spot for these kills that i have to do
for a trophy point is there are bigger
worlds i've seen in games but they're a
satisfying size
aided by the fact that there are
multiple worlds to go to and the weapons
the weapons in this game on the front of
quantity and quality satisfying on both
aspects the weapons are a lot of fun and
you get a lot of them
every time you level up a weapon you
unlock more on the ability chart that
you can then spend currency on to unlock
things like ammo capacity explosion size
you know things that you want for your
weapon then when you level it to level
five
it changes the name of it and it acts a
little differently the sniper rifle is
called the head hunter a name that makes
sense you level it to level five it's
now called the migraine and
anyone out there who suffers migraines
my fellow migraine sufferers
we're all like yeah perfect i appreciate
the fact that some of the trophies in
here are like you got to get this many
kills with this weapon or
these kinds of kills with this weapon
the reason i appreciate that is because
it forces you to use a gun that you
might not otherwise use and you might
find as i did that there are a few
weapons in this game that
speak to you a little more than you
might have initially thought they would
also appreciate the fact that when you
get a weapon or upgrade a weapon
or get the rocket boot so you can fast
travel which i mean it's not
like point and click fast travel it's
not like you teleport which
don't care i preferred blasting around
in my rocket boots that was just a fun
way to get around
very quickly but when you get any of
these things with say
ratchet rivet also has those upgrades i
didn't think they would i was like great
i have all the stuff with rivet and
all right time to start from scratch
with ratchet no
you don't have to you upgrade with rivet
you get it with ratchet
ratchet with rivets vice versa there's
no logical reason that when ratchet gets
something
rivet should have it other than the game
developers being like yeah we're just
not going to be decks i appreciate that
that was very convenient good call on
their part now if you're a stickler
for tough trophies you know you got your
blasphemous platinum you
got your dark souls platinums you're
ready this is not that this platinum's
very easy when you beat the game there
is this thing that tells you like oh hey
you can now do new game plus would you
get more currency
better versions of your weapons i was
like oh sweet bring it on
until starting new game plus getting to
the first vendor get you the last two
guns you needed and then i got my
platinum you should play games
for the joy of playing them sure but my
back catalog
of both retro games i've gotten and new
games but
the back catalog's crazy i mean dude i
gotta move on i got i gotta play other
things so i do wish there were more
trophies tied to the new game plus
element to keep me
there for longer so many games so little
time
you get the struggle and the action
scenes in this game were crazy intense
like some of the action sequences
reminded me of something out of an
uncharted game only with the addition
of going through dimensional rifts also
looks really slick when you find a rift
and you sling onto it and you
pull yourself to it or pull it to you
folks ratchet and clank rift apart i had
a blast with i loved the characters in
the game i love how they interact
together it was the game
i didn't know i needed and then i got it
i was like
this is it's one of those showcase games
for ps5 it shows what the ps5 can do
it's
early console generation so it's only
gonna look and play better than this as
we go
forward but you get a good sense of the
potential whether it's the ray tracing
blowing your hair back the adaptive
triggers you're being like oh yeah
that's what it's supposed to be like
because you you play mortal kombat 11
you play the ps5 upgrade on mortal
kombat 11 it's like adaptive they're not
it's just
the block button that's all it is some
games you don't really get a good sense
of it actually astros playroom
is the best like adaptive trigger
showcase there is
and sometimes you want a game you can
kick back enjoy it's
challenging enough without breaking your
balls over it i mean you could bump up
the difficulty sure absolutely but it
never loses the sense of oh yeah
fun video games that's what we're here
for but i was glad i played it it was
quite amazing in fact it was
awesome tacular
all right so ratchet and clank rift
apart have you played it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]
you